what's going on [ __ ] her face that's not
me
welcome back to rhythmic an evil DNA
code Veronica episode 2 I quit I think
we might be in dire straights I'm being
optimistic
but I'm I was told on Twitter that were
[ __ ] well you're supposed to help me I
beat this game once were apparently
you're not supposed to shoot that many
bullets and you know I told it that many
times but here we are sorry
you need a sling all right yeah I'm I'm
in caution that's not great I have an
Uzi that I don't think I'm supposed to
use I got a guy people are saying use
that because you can upgrade the handgun
down the road okay so I guess use those
okay get those stupid looking guns
um okay well then oh I will equip them I
gotta be honest with you that looks real
dumb she does look just holding that gun
to her chest okay I forget how to shoot
already I'm not saying this because I'm
trying or like subconsciously
objectifying her but I feel like they
put a lot of attention into like go on
her but I mean if she has a she's good
for her but like I feel like more
attention was paid to that than it was
in the first game I'm gonna say that as
a female player like Chris Redfield like
I like looked at that butt and I feel
like they put effort into that but okay
so maybe they just like you're obviously
looking at her but they probably just
like wanted the image sister and I look
at every characters but I look every
person's but in the real game butts no
real thoughts every person that's weird
that is weird no it's so we've been
getting numbers first five minutes are
one plus x I think hold on why I forgot
it you need to heal I think well I mean
I don't have to not and I'm not in red
I'm not in danger zone here so let's
recap you're in the palace I'm in the
palace things are not great
Oh actually go back check our inventory
feel like you've got something essential
I got a key card
the key card ID card it should open
something oh the computer in the lobby
downstairs had a needed a key card sorry
I'm still like
a huge portrait is on display here okay
that looks like Hitler right didn't that
there are some dictator I heard it okay
Silvercrest
all right sorry I saw that that's the
one lower than main your chair there we
go
you gotta get your posture down to my
level low I have bad posture terrible
posture me too it's really hard to
because there's just other things that I
want to work on in my life yeah I keep
my shoulders back successfully but I
also slump sitting there so yeah I think
that weird computer yeah yeah oh right
you need your employee ID all right
let's check it out it's time to see I'm
gonna check it out what's on this ideas
good J n TC n TC o 3 0 3 9 TC 0 3 9 4 no
no 0 9 3 4
no 0 3 9 shut up oh my god I'm actually
not and shut up shut up and TC 0 3 9 4
it's like that scene and like
we're like someone's counting and you're
just like 63 94 it's just like shut up I
have it I know what I'm doing yeah it's
making it harder my brain totally this
ID card is no longer used discard it
what's happening I'm gonna go to this
door okay it unlocks I think there's
another ones your left as well that
probably unlocked
I wonder that unlock the one upstairs if
that was like a no I wasn't ready for
the first on me I'm ready now
are you ready yeah
should I ignite them why are you asking
me if I'm right should I nice then let's
hold the knife things where you try it
so knife aimed down and knife its knees
I don't know how to kneel no no no
you're not the kneel just aim down when
you're when you have your knife out
press it down yeah oh [ __ ]
is that easy this way thanks to me
Rhonda's knife just get their news if he
dies done much come get some of this get
that booty was YouTube commenters really
screwing us over all right I'm gonna die
this isn't worth it apparently need to
get two hits in before they get to you
[ __ ] I don't think it's good to hurt I
don't think it's good to do when you
have that many zoms oh my god why are
they so spread out it's like jean-claude
Van Damme oh because there's someone to
your right
I'm sorry on me we wipe is it worth it
now persevere that's an evil way
never once it before it have we
purposely died before it's a wife yes
have we yes I don't think that's true
look at that I thought I was just
[ __ ] badass I thought I just looked
cool but you know that's actually really
hit the zombie but if someone was
telling me that that's a the angel
Archangel logo thing is a reference to a
metal album cool
that's meat still twitching look at his
little foot yes I can't I got so effed
up in that that was bad so I'm that I
was holding my guns cool that I forgot
to kill things
now she ends on the straight there's
guns all over the walls why can't you
pick those up maybe I can that was 9% of
the gun combat knives are displayed here
sweet how how neat well you can [ __ ]
reanimate dead bodies but you can't
break into a gun cabinet that's classic
nor what that play what what did that
plane thing say the plaque a model
fighter plane war never changes a model
gunship oh there's something linkies two
magnums a jewel displayed after a Nance
Wow that's not what the sense Matos
model is displayed all right I do I
believe I will I'm Dyslexic with numbers
often are you laughing yeah oh I love
that did you see that she was wounded in
the cutscene thing that's cool cuz you
suck alright I'm just kidding oh who are
these people
they're probably too gross that must be
Veronica oh that must be Veronica and
the other one is code oh it's the
Clifton's or whatever her name is
twins of those notes reference it's
always these blonde Aryan looking
[ __ ] that are creepy yeah jeez
make out I'm super uncomfortable that
might be the genuinely creepy thing I've
seen in this series don't take that long
for resin evil to actually scare me why
can't you take us
I got a steering wheel [ __ ] see if the
is reference why didn't I put the save
disks in the bin the ink ribbons yeah I
don't know
oh do you know how every right now I'm
full you wait you didn't even pick up a
steering wheel I did pick up the
steering wheel oh well you can go do
that now though save rooms just upstairs
oh that's uh I cannot place that you'll
die those are keys those uh was it
upstairs that the the gold Bluebird lock
was located I think I remember this this
room you're just in it twenty seconds
ago I remember being here not too long
ago we
doesn't that person know we're recording
Knievel seriously [ __ ] disrespect I'm
sorry I'm swearing a lot the disrespect
oh no I can't take it I need this so bad
I'm back this way a lot of handgun ammo
I don't know I think people are wrong
consumers about your future death have
been greatly exaggerated maybe [ __ ]
kill a person just kidding
it's Josh stupid josh Josh ow a chef
what's he doing tell me come out to
nothing I bet you he's all my company
almost nothing or b-wings or something
stupid like that
where was the save room I forgot already
yeah oops that's leaving you did that
last time too they all the stairs look
the same in this game if they're all
stairs
[Music]
astute observation they're all stirs I
probably actually have to mix those
herbs and take them because I think I'm
nearing death's door at this stage it's
not a great situation for marrying
actually while I'm at it
oops is there anything else I should get
rid of I guess keep the green herb so
you can combine it with the red dye I'm
gonna come in at the steering wheel for
now okay do you know what I don't get
rid of the steering wheel for now
oh okay do you know what I'm supposed to
be doing the golden Lugar's you saw a
lugar door before so you need those
unlock forgot where it was weather is in
the palace or in the military the prison
okay
oh is it here yes that's it right there
I think that's it something tells me
[Music]
clearly not paying attention it's okay
it's been a week wait I've had so many
streams this week I'm exhausted GDC week
is always filled with like developers
and these people come from out of town
it's like this fun like thing where
everyone's having fun and I'm like I
can't have fun because I'm too tired
yeah last night I did the first like PR
thing that I had known that PR thing go
to PR like an event 2k hosted something
yet the first time I did and a couple
interviews today with a Yin's my fists
the creative director at Wolfenstein -
Brendan Green came in we talked to him
Babji and tomorrow Yoko taro is coming
in along with Terrace on the Platinum
producer on the game Nier automata house
pub G going along so they weren't
allowed to talk about okay actually I
never talk about anything yeah well you
know they're working on the southeastern
Asia map which I'm looking forward to I
don't I'm not the biggest fan of the
desert map but that's probably because I
think the first map was like
i flawless but really really really good
oh [ __ ] I can't actually get through
there that's annoying you're not much of
a pop G fan are you I I play it I play
with friends I just find like by myself
I'm like camping very like hiding yeah
I'm like not in yeah it's like the most
exciting game Oh No
t move yes wait what is happening
inhale where's the panel right there
where that that's not it that's not it I
think I should put these guns back can
you put your hmm where was that I don't
know so [ __ ] hurt um yeah so it locks
me off interesting yeah my immediate
assumption is that we need fake Lugar's
or something yeah that makes sense but
also behind that there is find what
that's the panel right there that opened
up oh here
okay projections down we obviously are
like we're missing something in this
yeah check check that cabinet nothing
nothing I'll try this one
maybe use the steering wheel for now
wait what beetle it's like beetle with
all the jewels this guy it's an ant I
guess whatever I don't know I think
maybe we have to come back but then it's
like what do we do now
there's the door to the left oh yeah you
also yeah you unlocked another caution
where am I at
okay wait did you get the red herb oh
yeah you combined amar I should probably
take this and people were super excited
I jumped on the convince rain when I
first read it I thought they were saying
comon comon comon comon James Coleman
FBI director that's a silent be okay how
about this door yeah the one I ran past
it really good doors out I love the door
I've have been in here before haven't
you
I just don't remember his refund here I
got him on his stall oh I think
[Music]
i it does look familiar yeah oh wait
go back to the corner sorry this toilet
made out of marble people are saying
there's an herb in the stall I guess
that's the first thought you're in with
that fire hose and the dude in the
prison oh I missed it yeah but I think
you're so well I actually don't know
what to do now
steering wheel maybe we can go look for
something to do the steering wheel well
if we're gonna go look for something to
do with the steering wheel maybe I
should acquire the steering wheel how's
that sound
that's good parts spot to start
so you leave [ __ ] my kid selfies yeah
yeah I feel like a next reasonable thing
to do would be steering wheel or like
fake Aziz or
oops he like a steering wheel is
probably useful outside of the palace
that makes sense let's try that I've
already kind of like combed through this
entire place so I feel like at this
point I have to move on it's exciting
for me it's much like nemesis I haven't
played this game as much as the other
ones
great so you feel like you don't really
know what to do dude nemesis I struggled
with so much yeah but then for you
cruise through and five six
I yeah I was burning through four but
you like four right I liked four [ __ ]
yeah
wait is that outside or inside inside
she turned around for them look back in
here sorry I like didn't maybe the
downstairs door we mean
is it the bathroom oh that's what this
is no I meant like the the hallway you
should turn around wait
oh god what hallway the one with the
Psalms yeah and the red herb handguns
yeah okay got it hanging around that
make sense was that upstairs sorry no
it's here
Steve Steve do you hear anything
did you go through the double doors with
a heartbeat
[Music]
he got he [ __ ] did it you what an
idiot
Steve's suffering give a [ __ ] [ __ ] him
when two pairs complete my anger will
subside operate it there are switches
see that push which switch try a out or
F know start with an F ok
okay so
I'm assuming you want to match up C and
E what makes you say that
they're both guns I don't know they have
something in common Oh
oh my God look at these guns I'm keeping
it why let's make a deal I'll trade you
for something
fully automatic oh [ __ ] see you around
Claire adios [ __ ] Steve so I'm
assuming you have to trade the Uzis
which would imply that we did not use
them as much as we should and that was
my fault so I apologize
that's okay I I mean why didn't I give
him to him just then don't know he said
I'll trade you for something on fully
automatic and then he left and I wonder
where he went
wait what's down that side of the
hallway did you go there yeah yeah a
silver door Gold sorry and then there's
the double doors across to the left here
yes sorry there right you went there
silver
thank you okay my brain isn't totally
gone okay good to know
so silver Creston a gold Crest in there
hey you should move whoa dodges bullets
now no I'm telling you I have no idea
what you're babbling about
you don't fool me oh you must be one of
umbrellas lower level officers if you're
in command of a backwater base like this
one she's dragging on your base the
ashpit
family is among the world's first and
finest my grandfather is one of the
original founders of umbrella
umbrella Inc house umbrella Corp as
before now tell me
why have you attacked this installation
[Music]
shortly after you arrived my face was
that you must have informed your people
of its location
I still don't follow you I really don't
know anything about that
unacceptable how can you deny my face
has been destroyed and thanks to was
really little laser coming out of scope
what's your face you're just a rat in a
cage anyway I would despite all your
rage sounds like plankton or an ocarina
of time boss alright I just blew my mind
so that was weird um it didn't help me
or progress anything he's just like a
nut bag I guess I was weird wasn't that
weird dog wait how'd you get through
this door what do you mean clicked on it
no I mean like why is it unlocked now
this is always unlocked this is I got oh
you went outside left you've heard you
stuff back inside yeah do you hear this
yeah it's in the game what is it why am
i pointing at different directions again
they're pointing at the sky
I usually have some really smartass
comment don't know what to say
remember how I kept trying to pick this
up and I kept getting attacked a navy
proof wait where'd you get that on the
floor I was you there was stuff I missed
outside is this a bet this was a
backdoor you blocked in now this is the
way I came
oh yeah you're running from the dogs
when I first happened that's correct
what I said noise bugs I guess oh yeah
yeah there's bugs flying around the
lamppost I'm like what's this is this
like a place I've been before this is a
new place what happened
I just you didn't see it no I saw it but
where to go you didn't see it then what
happened you pushed him over the ledge
thing in chucked him right over
oh no I did not see it
wow I'm not paying attention we're not
there hold on hold on a second
bring back okay kill him
you wearing a baseball cap and nice keep
going keep going yeah yeah nice get
knifed damn that does work really well
sorry it looks it works well when
there's a couple 1/2 or fewer work oh
that was a weird camera thing before you
kill him can you bring up your pause
menu again why the [ __ ] does it say her
height is 5 point 5 4 5 feet that is
very particular
who needs that precision in their height
decimals sorry two people wearing
headphones was such a stupid mistake
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] injured now because you
dumb [ __ ] god bless it I was
following him to knife him like
I'm always injured in this game it's
been really long time since I have been
injured is this Rick ham from
yes
I still think Steve's still in the
palace for the record so should I go
back that's okay I'm not saying I'm not
saying this out of any knowledge of the
game I'm just saying that was that's my
gut instinct so it's very likely or
popular it's possible in abroad well
I'll be weird for him to run came here
for nothing then and got injured for
nothing you cleared out the zombie I'm
sure you're gonna have to go back
eventually because shield crest is well
there were two gates should I go out the
other gate I'll go out the other gate
and see if there was anything else in
there if this is the way I came from and
this is dog alley
[Music]
and I'll go this way and see if there's
anything else wait what oh no and so
there's an octagonal wait wait
submarine
obviously that means below water in
Latin that's a small submarine it's like
it's the name of the submarine The Life
Aquatic with Steve Zissou
he's one shouldn't [ __ ] know this one
my favorite movie it's a woman's name
Jackie yeah he crosses out the name and
gondola Shirley Ashley did you just say
Jackie yeah that's super weird because
it's Jacqueline and then he crosses it
out and says deep searched were you
saying that of prior knowledge I read
joking I was just saying lady names I
also said gondola which isn't a lady
named and I love that movie dogs please
don't kill me
what is happening am i under water
that's how these things work
hey why'd you leave cuz I wanted to know
[Music]
what is happening I went down some water
wait did you press anything in this
subject yeah where are you me I pressed
a lever and then I went downtown and
then I left the submarine and now I'm in
this place what a weird game it is weird
like Dynel prizes at some point I hear
his arms [ __ ] yeah it's getting too
boring around here how many one looks
like he's dressed in World War 2 uniform
you know how I feel I can handle one
yeah that's - no just you're fine just
as dude no you're fine just as long as
you yessiree come on he's gotta get
twice before he gets to you [ __ ] him up
yeah yeah I did it I did it just the way
we talked [ __ ] but it's not worth all
the hell's I'm losing you [ __ ] nuts
it's not worth it it's not worth it
this isn't worth it [ __ ]
[Music]
so [ __ ] come on
danger there's bullets everywhere you've
a lot of bullets why are we living like
this I didn't need to do that I think
we're fine allow me to be the blind
optimistic one blindly AAPIs I'll be
playing realistic that was bad
I just lost [ __ ] I'll shoot people you
just shoot them that's new yeah I
expected it's the same like there's got
to be a compilation of door opening I
hear bats so I'm tempted to get my
lighter out what do you think do you
think there's a door opening compilation
and YouTube like a thug and all the
doors that's cool I would watch that
I'll make it if I have to would it be
set to the songs of the doors though or
the save music so my PlayStation 4 theme
at home is the rebel 20th anniversary
which is the save music from remake and
too shiny
I've traveled really far today but I
don't know if I've accomplished anything
also I have not saved in a while and
it's concerning yeah I don't know if
you've noticed that looks important
[Music]
it's a lot load it's a control panel for
the shutter k40 - oh [ __ ] I know where I
am
there's no zoms that's good
yeah
[Music]
should I pick up the big box yeah just
to get another way that's sweet
oh man I find love crane games
well what yes there's a door over here I
should probably go in there and Resident
Evil was that on this show that where
there was a crane with a like a garbage
chute
yes that was resident evil witch game I
should know this
five right no no sorry for oh yeah for
it was I was it was a while into for it
was not for it was not you could see me
there reflection I can see you it was
for like that's not for him
okay just win the argument I'm gonna
search this I think I was five I can't
remember about entropy it's a crane game
resin will for waste treatment plant
damage yeah okay so um I gonna say I
told you so
but she's like see you and they're
reflected in your stupid face there's
something my boss
it's a soulless eyes people are telling
me I have expressive eyebrows today
apparently when I get frustrated or
angry if they start quivering I don't
realize it the lift may not operate if
the power levels are low the power
levels low what was that I heard
zom zom bronies well I came up oh yeah
woozi just [ __ ] go - yeah just [ __ ]
them up I'm not ready so [ __ ] bad-ass
[ __ ] yeah god that was the coolest thing
you've ever done the whole point of
these is ease why are you tapping I
think you can hold it there automatic I
tried that was painfully cool I was
really worried about dying okay I don't
think I can take both of these items
unfortunately but I can take this
biohazard actually I can take both it's
the name of the game biohazard code
Veronica in Japan oh I already saw this
- I got a I got a thing to carry more
stood aside
well I'm gonna read this one more time
Kate 402 so that's gonna come in to hint
like come into play at some point but I
don't know how I am and I have a new key
card your birthday's coming up yeah
what's that well it already happened
are you serious man say wait as of this
publishing or yeah right now no it
happened my birthday is March 18 o'clock
I'm sorry it's okay
belated thanks I like don't make a big
deal out of it I have like a little
party this weekend
with Peter Brown to celebrate I go there
both of our combo DVD been there the
last two years we both like each other
where's my mom's birthday is the 16th my
sister is the Saint Patty's Day 17th my
aunt's is your birthday and then my
cousin's is the 15th Wow it's almost
like you have no excuse to forget it
then yeah the my propensity to remember
things to commensurate with how much I
care about that person I have a lighter
[ __ ] off
push the Xbox instead push the switch
push the PlayStation something's missing
wait go back to this thing you have one
but put that one thing in you have right
now but the one thing I have in know in
your inventory you have like that
hexagonal thing oh right I'm assuming
you need two others
maybe proof yeah looking freed up one
space at least
okay so let's horn let's chill for a
second this seems to be your main
objective you need to find two others
hexagonal items okay hexagonal hex on
hexagon on hexagonal hex nog n'l butter
stop signs had six sides
I don't know why that would affect
anything we didn't that's a very huge
couch hold on did you see that yeah go
back through the door to appease this
weird thing that you've noticed weird
thing it would the couch line the entire
room okay
don't even tell me it's not weird
weirdly huge couch to have a long couch
look okay look at how long this couch is
it's the wall it's longer than the
average couch thank you I'm just gonna
walk down this just in case okay it
looks like there's nothing okay so I
have a new key card
oh you're later out as well listen you
never know when you're gonna come across
the bat I don't [ __ ] with bats - cheese
doesn't matter I feel like I should save
how long has it been since we saved
beginning the episode so like 45 minutes
I have anxiety Wednesday we have another
15 minutes in the episode ish but I
don't want to lose
[Music]
well of [ __ ] okay so let's keep
in mind that eventually your once you
find two other hexagonal hexagonal
pieces you're gonna have to return to
the submarine and go down okay you say
blob blob [ __ ] yes I assume
that's what submarines would say
seems like a really extra use of that
steering wheel what it does she's a she
adds a flourish to it let's go find
Steve [ __ ] is he up there yeah what's he
like I don't know what two guns or some
[ __ ] what it twerp there was an extra
little area back there it's probably
nothing but I might just go and look my
arm out bunch of cats I can't believe
I'm so injured I hope I hope there's
health in here really really are you
been here
but hey you been here what bonus nothing
nothing from Mary okay so I have a key
card but I don't know where it goes I
think of like a door that I've seen
that's like key card II I can't think of
one
I just want nowhere Steve on it you
could save it if you want well not if
he's got cuz I only got so many pucks
yeah I think you're fine but like what
do I do with this key card you know yeah
do you know where I should go next you
have any thoughts I guess it would be
somewhere around here but maybe he went
back to the prison the other ones the
bathroom this is the hallway where I got
[ __ ] up your Silvercrest for that gold
yep and then the gold crest on the end
but I can go in here but he came out of
here right yeah so he's not in here like
maybe but I doubt it you got the Lugar's
oh sorry he has them right freedom and I
need them so am I going back to the
prison yeah probably
unless he's up in the same room which
you I don't I think he checked and I
think yes I trying to think if I've been
to the save room in a while I actually
don't think I've been to the same room
but you think he'd be in there no well I
don't know he the way he was talking it
sounded like he was going close by ish
wait okay I'm gonna look and then we'll
go to the prison okay but I'm not gonna
save because I only have so many pucks
what am I doing with this key card this
must have something to do with a
biohazard card so it's either here or
you have any items you can dump off
right now I don't think so
I like kind of want know I can get rid
of this that's probably fine right
wait what trying to think yeah let's go
back to prison I don't know what else to
do
it's gotta be
it seems right so far away though the
prison you know oops that's the bathroom
this is the entryway if I go find that
silver thing then we could do it
the Silvercrest those bugs are so
annoying they're very loud I feel like I
should take that yeah I'm not in a great
state here Wyoming you anti Wyoming
no I why am i fine it was just the state
if anything of a negative one
no twelve of our viewers
I love Wyoming I grew up in upstate New
York okay I it's not the best place to
like it was boring I could talk [ __ ]
about other bad places
Wyoming's probably lovely alright so
we've done this and now I go all the way
[ __ ] back mm-hm
Jackson Hole is nice that's Wyoming
right it's Missouri seriously I don't
know I should know that I've went I was
in Missouri for a while
and what the Arkansas for two years
University of Arkansas in Fayetteville
Arkansas cool yeah no one cares I don't
I think there's zombies here have you
gone down oh this is like a sidebar
thing I feel everyone really far out of
the way here so I hope this is a good
call
cuz you know we got bad I just thinking
of where did that come from
yeah it's GDC week and then dying light
was showing off there there's a bunch of
zombies in here alright [ __ ] yeah
I love the way she holds us it's very
cool
get on the ground get on the ground in
poop blood is there anything over here
doesn't look still fall anything over
here I feel like I've already been here
like what we have just trying to think
of like what else is going on don't work
cuz you use that card
this is dog area I killed all the dogs
you know I haven't been reusing lysing
my map if you noticed that there's
there's this red thing here I'm pretty
sure you should not have come this far
back what I don't I don't want to like
tell you exactly where you got all right
go back to the bridge I think that's
where you went wrong the bridge there's
another way from there that I think you
should have gone but there's this red
you've been here before though yeah I
know but I haven't been in that red
thing you haven't oh [ __ ]
clearing out some zooms yeah but for
what purpose make it safer next time you
come back and you know you need to come
back here there's that um what was the
door here yeah indentation of a blue
plate indigo indentation indignation
indignation yes okay twitching alright
so go back to the bridge I think so okay
he's saucing being wrong all the time
I'm so tired
oh come on [ __ ] him up well yeah why
they back that's not it back
how the tank controls feeling I mean
still tanky getting the hang of it but
it's a bummer that like keep getting
hurt okay okay this bridge believe so
what am I looking for
there's another door off here no no no
sorry
closer to the palace okay so not this
bridge there's another bridge
yeah
we bridges are in this game one two five
unify me you know I feel about bridges
you seen a bridge on the river kwai
alright there's a door did you try going
through that door to the right yeah this
one said it's closed can you use is
there like a hole and go back go back go
back
okay go back to the door
go to those can you switch to the left
oh there's a switch to the left or I
it's the same color right okay here we
go
seems like I'm fine oh my god is the
Sabah's
oh my god I didn't save you should avoid
this just go I don't think you have to
fight it if memory serves yeah I just
run ideally somewhere that will get you
here's my here so okay here's my
suggestion it's almost been an hour I
think that's good too why don't we save
and we do it well I don't think you have
to fight the boss is my thing
I remember you can avoid this right now
episode the teaser for next time
you deal with the the worm feeling
accomplished very much this episode hey
did you have to cut scenes gulp whatever
that [ __ ] blah blah blah [ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ]
blah blah this way you said yeah
I met a bad guy oh my god that [ __ ]
worm I'm not dying no worm not dying a
no worm today not before I save once
whoo that was a close one
it was not my best episode yeah what was
the one where I beat resident evil 3
yeah that was an accomplishment oh I
don't how many your increments problems
like not having a lot of increments is
so stressful I think you have more than
that and your inventory don't you I
think I only have two but I have more in
you know how like I had to get rid of
them because they were metal oh yeah so
I have some in a bucket not yeah I don't
know how many but alright wait
it could have been worse No
it's not my best what we think it's so
far so what sorry I just messed up our
headphones what's our thing we're trying
to potentially fight that worm maybe a
boy like that [ __ ] worm or I'm
at least gonna get whatever's behind
there we need to get two more hexagons
II pucks to do the submarine thing I
need a silver a gold key I need a lot of
stuff I'm completely locked out of
everything so I guess I'm finding things
to get in there we have the biohazard
card and you know that Steve has a Luger
so once you find him you can get through
the door and there saver I'm upstairs in
the palace that makes sense
sweet all right I think you accomplished
more than you feel like you did I got
hurt a lot yeah but he looks really cool
killing those people with good flap flap
[ __ ] that's my catchphrase hash
phase redfish
okay glub glub [ __ ] yeah well what
what is today people are watching it on
the first day it's Saturday Saturday 3
p.m. Pacific we usually put these up 3
p.m. Pacific okay I'm Scott I don't have
a good there was a firefight
a few seconds this place was [ __ ]
Armageddon bomb dropping on me to eat it